ces suppressions de postes chez air
france huit à dix mille emplois en moins
c'est ce que prévoit le plan de la
compagnie aérienne en réponse à la crise
ducobu de 19 ans chiffre qui représente
près de 20% des effectifs des
suppressions répartis entre les
personnels au sol
les hôtesses les stewards et les pilotes
ces départs devrait se faire sur la base
du volontariat et pour en parler en
direct avec nous car in monségurais
l'écho secrétaire général de la cgt air
france
on vous remercie d'être en direct avec
nous alors c'est bien la crise du kobe
19 qui a motivé à ces suppressions de
postes
disons que cette crise permet
d'accélérer le plan de transformation de
l'entreprise que benjamin smith avait
présenté aux investisseurs en novembre
2019 donc il était prévu d'opérer cette
transformation c'est à dire de supprimer
des emplois et de précariser davantage
les personnels et cette situation du coc
u19 permet à la direction d'air france
comme à d'autres directions dans
d'autres entreprises d'accélérer les
orientations retenues et de faire en un
an ou en quelques mois ce qui était
prévu de se faire un horizon 2023 2024
alors bruno le maire parle de départs
volontaires il dit d'ailleurs refusèrent
les départs contraints concrètement que
les départs volontaires est ce que c'est
vraiment possible quand on parle de la
suppression d'à peu près dix mille
emplois non alors vous savez la parole
de monsieur le maire on la connaît il
n'est pas très crédible
la question du nombre de suppressions
d'emplois va nécessairement
imposer des départs non donc je l'en
terre et qui pour la cgt constitue une
préoccupation majeure et dont nous
pensons qu'il faut que nous organisions
la riposte à la fois avec la cgt et puis
en intersyndicale puisque nous avons
recréé une intersyndicale comme c'était
le cas lors du conflit sur le sujet des
salaires du temps monsieur janaillac
et donc là de notre notre volonté
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas nous
d'essayer de faire est de créer les
conditions pour que nous n'ayons pas à
subir une orientation une stratégie et
des choix qui ne répondent pas à
l'intérêt collectif des salariés et à
celui aussi des passagers ou parmi
justement à l'instant d'un plan de
riposte quelles sont les actions que
vous envisagez les recours peut être
engagée alors on a un certain nombre de
recours au niveau de la cgt par rapport
à ce qu'il se passe dans le cadre de
négociations que ben smith conduit avec
les seuls pilotes excluant de fait les
autres représentants des autres
catégories socioprofessionnelles de
l'entreprise
et puis après sur les modes d'action que
nous allons mettre en oeuvre
je pense qu'elles ne seront pas
télévisée alors ce plan de
restructuration il est encore un peu
flou il est pas encore déterminé ce sera
début juillet froid le 4 juillet ou le 3
est-ce que d'ici là vous pensez qu'il y
aura peut-être des ajustements ont été
faits à ce plan écoutez on à la
regrettable habitude depuis plusieurs
années d'apprendre ce tout se passe dans
l'entreprise par les médias là nous
avons eu confirmation ce matin que le
prochain csc se déroulera le 3 juillet
il est bien évident qu'en ce qui
concerne l'intersyndicale nous n'allons
pas attendre de 3 juillet pour nous
organiser je pense que l'objectif visé
par la direction
c'est de se séparer d'un maximum de
salariés comme le fait la direction de
british airways et de lufthansa pour
envoyer des messages forts aux
actionnaires et qu' il convient que nous
organisations syndicales en soit
suffisamment organisés pour infléchir
ses orientations
parce que ce la volonté de la direction
et puis du gouvernement d'ailleurs enfin
bon c'est un peu pareil vous me direz
c'est les mêmes gens c'est de faire
payer la crise au monde du travail et
donc il n'est absolument pas question
que ce soit les travailleurs et des
travailleuses qui paye cette situation
ternit de monségur je rappelle que vous
êtes comme secrétaire général de la cgt
air france merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous